the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I think so today's lecture is about it's
supposed to be about navigation but in
many ways that can be a pretty dry
subject so what I've done is I've made
it very graphical and and sort of active
and animated no this is just a folder
this isn't the version anyway so a
couple of administration pieces is the
sprint submission deadline so the Sprint
tournament will be held on Wednesday but
you need to submit your code by Monday
at midnight there's a little bit of
wiggle room where you can submit it like
a few hours after midnight but don't
plan on that yeah and you submit your
code to the Sprint tournament and that
makes you eligible to win prizes so and
it also helps you with your seeding so
that you'll be seeded into a higher part
of the tournament bracket for the next
tournament so yeah it got to get started
early we'll also be offering another
source of money for you as if you didn't
have enough sources of money with the
Sprint tournament and all of those
special prizes were giving you Adam the
tournament itself we're also offering an
extra prize for the team that is most
helpful to other teams and people so
that means that now you have an
incentive beyond just being a good
person to help other teams out we'll
have it like a survey that goes out in
the last week and so if you've like
gangsters everybody into voting you as
helpful then you'll win the prize
without being helpful so just you know
keep that in mind all right
so today we're supposed to talk about
navigation let's have a look at this
thing here is a program that I wrote
that makes a maze
piece by piece there's probably a
smarter way to do it but I just built
random walks that self avoid onto one
another to make a maze and what I've
done here is I've got a variable called
delay that lets me change the speed at
which a computation is performed so you
can see here if I set it to 0.5 then
we'll be here all day because each one
of these paths is gonna take a half a
second to put together but this is
helpful because a lot of times you know
a pathing routine will happen instantly
or in compute time it'll happen fast and
you won't really notice what's going on
so let's let's go ahead and set this to
a small number now we've got a
app that has a bottom left and an upper
right and we're gonna use this map to
demonstrate a bunch of pathing
techniques so we're trying to get from
the bottom left to the upper right the
first method we're gonna use is
depth-first search so I'm gonna run this
oh it finished that was dumb let's make
the delay 0.1 yeah so now you can see
I'm starting from the left and I'm going
along in a depth-first search which
means that I'm looking toward the end
first and then after I have investigated
everything I'll start again at the next
branch point so I haven't even looked at
this I've I've gone along and yeah so I
checked that up done okay so now you can
see it finished but I'm gonna run it
once more and I want you to keep your
eye on the colors that have displayed on
the right here the color indicates how
far it thinks something is and it's
scaled from white to black so when it
finds something that's darker it will
brighten up this other area and so
having you know having systems are
basically just a way of finding a way of
trying all the possible combinations but
there are little tricks of making that
smarter I'll do I'll show one last time
the point is to make it smarter than
trying every possible combination like
like for example if you visited an area
before then don't try that again or if
you visited an area before and you got
there closer than you currently are then
don't try that again so there you have
it there's an example of depth-first
search and we're gonna move on and show
an example of breadth-first search
search to show how different it is
they're gonna look pretty similar for
this example but the next example I give
won't be passing in a maze it'll be
passing in something that's more open so
here's here's a breadth-first search and
you can see it's it's sort of parallel
pursuing paths like it's doing a little
down here and a little down there and
it's jumping back and forth between
things that have the same depth I'm
gonna show it again and I want you to
pay attention to the colors specifically
white and black you see that it never
goes back and updates a point all at
once it does
bit by bit so you see areas are
gradually lightening rather than
lightening all at once so I'll show this
one more time this is breadth-first
search on this maze computed in real
time I can change this maze and it'll
come out again for the explicit purpose
of show of demonstrating the concept I
actually had to go to the trouble of
writing a breadth-first search it's not
that hard at least in Mathematica and
I'm pretty sure it's not hard in any
language to write something that works
and we'll talk more about that later but
I know a lot of you have already heard
of a lot of concepts in navigation and
you've also got Wikipedia you could just
go online and find oh I see these are
the things that are important for that
so let's move on now we have a bug
navigation bugs
apparently find their way around rooms
and things by walking until they hit an
object like a wall and then they just
follow along the wall there's also a
well known truth or truism or something
like that where if you're in a maze and
you put your hand on one wall and you
follow that wall then you'll find the
end of the maze so let's let's sort of
let's try to watch that at work actually
let's make the speed 0.05 so here we've
got a bug and he's walking wrong along
the yellow represents his left hand no
the yellow is his right hand and he's
following the left wall so you can see
he's going around to the left he's
really not finding the fastest path from
the bottom left to the upper right but
the point is he'll get there so there
you go he found his way there I'll show
that again a bit slower so the goal here
is when you when you program a bug
pathing system it's that the guy has to
remember what direction he he has been
going because if he is just in a
position just any given position so I'll
pause it at some point say here so maybe
he's here how is he gonna know whether
he was going down or up
you know he's that's the way that he
remembers his current state is the
direction now that's like the big thing
about bug is that
it doesn't need any memory at all its
memory is sort of encoded in its
position and its direction and that's
all it needs
whereas other forms of having you got to
store these lists and how long they are
and you know where they go and which
lists are their parent parent lists or
parent nodes but bug is very simple
again it doesn't you know it's not
really that fantastic at getting you
where you need to go and you might also
ask the question what do you do when
you're not in a maze so let's go ahead
and answer that question of what you do
when you're not in a maze and we can go
over the details of you know how to
implement bug if we you know if we have
time at the end but you cannot you can
look all that stuff up right so just in
brief summary we've looked at depth
first search breadth first search and
bug pathing I'll talk more about the
details of each one but you know I like
to just sort of go through once and go
through again with more detail so let's
change it to an alternative maze this
isn't what you're gonna have for
battlecode that would be terrible
mazes are not that exciting in terms of
video games here is an example of the
kind of map you'd have for battlecode
and what depth-first search is trying to
do to locate the shortest path so first
it's going deep it's gonna go it's gonna
keep going on its path until it finds
the end now there are ways of making
depth-first search where it won't do
what it's doing now which is kind of
silly what is it doing filling space
with this line and all these possible
combinations of filling space with this
line this is just wasting our time here
it wants to go from there to there
what's it doing over here
so that that's an example we're gonna
make this run as fast as it can run so
let's let's pause the evaluation and
we'll run it again and so you can see
now it's faster but it's still trying a
whole lot of punch a whole bunch of
combinations that it just don't make any
sense it's here it goes along the left
here it goes along this side okay it's
gonna try verticals okay now it's gonna
try all these okay sweep sweep sweep
sweep sweep sweep sweep
now let's hope for God God's sake don't
try that all God tried there
ah well okay now that it's try this area
let's hope it doesn't go keep trying
these different things like up here
let's hope it doesn't go back there
that'd be such a waste of time so here
it's going Oh what is this it's going
he's looping around and spinning and now
it's Oh finally
man I'm gonna fire that guy let's see if
breadth-first search can do any better
let's keep the delay at point one and
see what happens oh let's see it's
searching the nearby paths rather than
going down one that's deep
I see it doesn't seem to be crossing
overall ground too much so if it's
located this point it's not going to try
ten different ways of getting to this
point one of the features of
breadth-first search is that if the if
the distance between nodes is uniform
like the every square is the same
distance from every other square then as
soon as you find the end you've found
the closest the the shortest path to get
to the end so what we're gonna see is
that it's not going to keep looking
after it finds this tile it's just gonna
stop Bing okay it's all done once it
looked at that depth wow that was pretty
convenient well let's see how bug does
on the same map now this is just showing
the the last result let's see what
result bug gets it's not going to look
like this so there it is it moved along
and followed this wall and then it
stopped bugging along the wall and then
it followed this wall and now it's
bugging along that way are we in a loop
nope nope we're not in a loop it's
following along this way and thing it
got to the result pretty exciting let's
show that one or two more times to
explain what's going on when it's trying
to do this as soon as it hits a wall bug
has to decide if it's gonna go left or
right later on I'm gonna talk about you
know why that can end up being a huge
problem you'll see it left the yellow
ball behind
I only update the position of the yellow
ball when I am in bug mode so the point
of bugging in open terrain is that you
have to be able to leave the bugging so
you have to be able to stop bugging at
one point and start just branching off
or else for example if the goal where
somewhere away from a wall you'd never
get to it generally a criteria for
leaving the bugging condition is if you
are closer to the goal than you were
when you started bugging I see a
question this one here right now when
the bug is not connected to a wall I
have it going in the direction that is
toward the goal so here this is like the
worst possible map because just when it
wanted to go toward the goal it hit
another wall so that's why it turned
inward and that's also why it turns
inward over here and over there so
that's that's that's a very good
question so let's watch it again and
what I want to point out as well is that
the yellow is places it wants to turn so
here it wants to make a right turn and
here it leaves bugging because it was
closer to the destination here than it
was when it was farther back over here
so yeah once again it's moving along and
it'll go around and we'll find the
answer so it's not very good looking but
if your obstacles don't connect with the
edge of the wall it can find you
sometimes the same result that you would
get otherwise so I'm gonna open up
something like word and I'm gonna make
some notes because I can type faster
than I can write on the board and that
makes a lot of sense let's talk about
metrics of success in having there's the
time to arrive that you want to have a
narrow distribution of times to arrive
if you're a if you're padding a group of
units like you know if you're trying to
get to the other side you really want
them arriving in a Congo line that's
that's potentially gonna get them killed
one by one you want to you sometimes
want to explore the map as well and
there are ways of you know manually
working out some of these things what's
the best path to explore the map and so
on but these are just things to keep in
mind and let's look at some sort of a
comparison between bug and and
depth-first and breadth-first search so
the the bug system is computationally
fast but at the same time you know
you've got your own trade off between
byte codes
compute time it but it uses the unit
turn and you can do that in two ways
with battle with battle code you can do
it with Direction dot rotate right which
will rotate you which will rotate that
direction 45 degrees or you can do it by
using as we did in the example yesterday
direction dot values which gets you
eight Direction values starting with
north and going all the way around to
north west and then you can increment
this this index so if you're starting at
direction east that would be too because
it's north north east east
so you that would be two and then you
can just add one to rotate right add
another one to rotate right again and so
on it's pretty interesting that bug can
work blind in battlecode usually when
you do pathing you want to do something
like sense game objects so that you
could say all right I want to sense game
objects of robot class I want a sense
that type of game object and I want to
mate I want all of them because I want
to make sure I don't run into any of
them in previous years you would have
also had to do sense terrain tile or
sense yes it would be something like it
would be for for a given map location
you could you could sense yeah it would
be like our seed for robot controller
dot sense terrain tile and it would be a
given map location and a or something
and you would put it and you'd say is
this equal to terrain tile dot terrain
type dot off map or it would be void or
it would be or it would be like open or
something like that and it was a huge
bother so we got rid of void spaces and
so now you're basically trying to say I
need to use the enemy mine locations and
I believe there's sense enemy mine
locations or something or some method
like that but you don't need those
because I said the bug is blind you
could just get by with can move and that
you know that can be pretty nice if
we're not making giant mazes you could
probably just get by using can move if
can't move then you know rotate in some
direction that may also end up being
cheaper computationally than using these
methods for the same bugging like I'm
saying bugging with can move or bugging
with sense game objects I mean for this
kind of stuff I always find it useful to
go into the release where I've where
I've got the folder where I've installed
battlecode check my method costs I say
all right let's see here
can move here it is cost me 25 byte
codes how much does it cost for me to
sense robot info because I'm gonna get
robots I'm gonna have to sense their
info in order to get their location that
also cost me 25 but that's after the
costs associated with sort of sensing
all nearby game objects which cost me
100 plus all that other stuff I've got
to do to sort of make setup a loop with
checking and and savings no way that's a
different thing
so yeah we've got we've got a blind
we've got it's blind you should check
your leave bugging criterion can be
something like patience just after a
certain amount of time give up distance
are you closer than you were before
direction how many times have you turned
left and right if you keep track of that
then it can say all right I've gone
around a barrier I know that because of
that number of times I've turned so now
I can be intelligent about leaving that
bugging so finally there's with mass
pathing using bug you should consider
distinguishing between off map void
friend and foe and here void is more
realistically said to be neutral Minds
I've said before but I'll remind you
that you don't know where enemy mines
are until you've stepped on them so
that's sort of a difficulty neutral
mines are more realistic to path around
and you could consider writing a rush
player which locates the optimal way to
get from one base to another because you
know the bases you know where they are
you know where the neutral mines are to
begin with so if you have some of your
robots for the hedge the headquarters
for example compute the optimal path
between your main base and the enemy
base you could rush there more quickly
than you would otherwise it's not really
going to work with enemy mines though
because as I said you don't
see them so you might want to
distinguish between these different
types of obstacle because if the if a
foe is in the way do you want to Pat
them around around him or do you want to
just stop and start shooting I mean of
course in this battle code you don't
have to explicitly shoot and you move
and you shoot simultaneously it's worth
it's worth mentioning here that you
shoot after you move that's something
that isn't entirely obvious you might
say okay it doesn't matter whether you
shoot before or after that's just a
little detail but it ends up being super
important especially in what we're gonna
see later what we'll see is that lets
say one robot of yours and one robot of
the enemies are nearby
if the enemy moves toward you then it
will immediately do damage let's say
that you subsequently move away from the
enemy because you want to say rejoin
your group well you will move away and
then not do damage so the two of your
robots will move along in some direction
and you'll take damage every time and he
won't take any damage at any time it'll
be no good another thing is that if you
have neutral mines two paths around well
those aren't going anywhere so you
better path around them but if you have
friends two paths around maybe you
should just wait for them to get out of
the way
because presumably they are also having
somewhere and so there's probably just a
traffic jam and does it make more sense
for you to go running off in another
direction or to just have some patience
and wait there for the friend to move at
the same time the thing that I described
the other day surely applies here where
you have a wall of enemy units here and
you've got me and you've got like a
bunch of allies here and I want to be
here at my icecream
but I can't get there because allies are
in the way and I'm waiting for them to
move and they're waiting for me to move
together with all these other guys that
are all boxed boxed up behind this chunk
of Mines so yeah you could realize you
get in some trouble this beautiful
diagram by the way I saved I save so
much chalk that way I tell you let's see
so now we talked a little bit about mass
pathing I'd like to mention one or two
other aspects you could leave room for a
bend and one way you could do that is
you could say
alright I'm I realize there's a corner
here and the first guy that goes around
that way will mark this as the as the
Waypoint then other guys can go straight
to the Waypoint or if they're even
smarter they'll try to go around the
Waypoint so for example this guy could
say he could mark all of these positions
as undesirable and they could like
radiate a force outward so that every
other robot is like being repulsed by
these X's and at that point you might
start to have the situation which would
be emergent behavior where your robots
are starting to intelligently sort of
have multiple lanes around the obstacle
rather than having just one lane and
getting backed up behind one another so
here they're getting backed up and here
they would be sort of fanning out in a
sort of pretty way yeah and you're gonna
see later the effect of fanning out I
mean of course you've seen it and you
can imagine how strong it would be on
the outcome of a battle but that's gonna
be really important when we talk about
sort of the emergent behavior of your
army when you take into account local
information about where people are
standing I hope you guys like the
analogy that I said to my email I
thought it was a little bit contrived
but not too terrible not not too
terribly ok it was pretty terrible okay
so in Mass pathing also consider your
execute ordering as we've mentioned
before if if you have guys in a line and
their robot IDs are 1 and then 2 and
then 3 and then 4
yeah this is real pretty then they can
move left because they'll execute in
this order oh man it's like it's
animated oh jeez but they can't move to
the right because this guy's in the way
so number 1 will be like I don't know
where to go I'm gonna go there number
twos like well I can't go here or here
maybe I'll go up there he gets lost his
heads cut off
yes two can move down here there's a
dirt diagonal directional movement yeah
and three could move down there and then
I guess four could like move here cuz he
doesn't know that the others did it
would be kind of cool if they did that
and then they would just like shimmy
along and be like an inchworm that
because that'd be pretty cool
oh gosh paint paint paint don't do this
to me there that's much better so they
could do this but four would have to be
pretty darn smart it's more like
that by now like these guys are inch
warming along and fours like over there
and eventually three gets sort of spread
out and and I don't know one just goes
and he gets tired of the whole deal
because he's been looking at twos behind
the whole game so yeah you definitely
want to keep in mind the execution order
and when I say keep in mind I mean you
could actually do sort of like a bubble
sort
where if if your ID is different from
the guy who's behind you you could just
switch places with them and try to get
behind it because you can use you know
you can use the function my robot
controller dot get ID and you'll have
your ID and you can you can remember
when we did robot and we said you know
all allied robots or something equals
our C dot sense nearby game objects the
most helpful function name in the world
and we said robot dot class you could
say all right all I'm interested in is
the guy behind me please give me the
allied guy behind me well you don't need
to get all the nearby game objects you
could say alright I want the one who is
adjacent to me so he's within a distance
of one or say two if you want to include
diagonals and then I also want to make
sure that he's on my team so I do RC
that get team so now immediately I've
got a nice list of allied robots that
are nearby if I want to get that their
ID numbers it's as simple as R C dot
sense robot info and I sense one of
their Infosys is a robot which I can
pull out of the list by doing you know
something simple like you know I'll
locate the closest one in the ordinary
way that you would expect so I've got
the robot info and robot info includes
actually I think you might even be able
to get get ID from robot hi where would
I go to check I would just simply go to
the documentation in the release all
classes - frame I would see robot info
just try to see or maybe let's see if
robot has Oh robot has get ID look at
that so I don't even have to sense robot
info I can just go straight so here I
can just say I'm not gonna say I'm just
gonna do a robot dot get dot what was a
get ID I think it was either get ID or
ID and now I'll have that ID and I can
compare it to my own and so on as I said
so this is all about bugging and mass
pathing in a simple way if you want to
do it smarter you can use a star which
is a breadth-first search you can look
up on Wikipedia and it's is making a
list of where you can go that's it
that's as simple as it is you
listen you're keeping that list pruned
down so that it hasn't got all these
extra places for you to look at so it's
shorter to get to your goal and it can
and what it can also do is incorporate
heuristics we'll be talking a little bit
about heuristics today where we're
saying it's a fancy word that to the
extent I understand it just means that
the distance between one Square and
another is not necessarily one or the
goodness of being in one square or
another is not necessarily the same so
maybe you want a path from point A to
point B but you don't want to cross a
particular obstacle I saw once that
somebody did a giant paper I think they
did a PhD thesis on the Traveling
Salesman problem and they had solved the
Traveling Salesman problem under the
condition that they were traveling in
the United States and they did not want
to cross the Mississippi River that's so
beyond me why would you I love them
crossing the Mississippi River but
anyway he didn't want to so he did that
and I think he got I think he went ahead
and got now now that I remember it was
probably it was actually a high school
science fair PhD science fair same thing
so you can incorporate these heuristics
and it's just a method it's just a way
of saying like here I've got this list
of locations that I'm going to and I'm
just gonna associate goodness or badness
with them and at the end instead of
saying distance I'll just say goodness
or badness it's as simple as that and
that's how that's how those things end
up getting done and and and so on
there's also D star and a whole plethora
of other things this is like start from
the destination and go to the start I
mean there's like various reasons to do
this there's tangent bug where you're
saying like alright I recognize a
certain pattern to a star and D star if
I start at this location and I end here
at E and the obstacles sort of look like
this well the only reasonable place is
for me to go in this open continuous
terrain is tangents between the two
things so I can draw a tangent there I
can draw a tangent there from my
starting position I draw a tangent to
there you see these tangents they're
right angles it's beautiful there's one
here okay that's the right angle
this guy's got a tangent here and he's
got
there there's some like arbitrary dumb
ones that never apply such as like this
one or like this one that well in any
case there are ways of pruning it so
that you've got just the right tangent
and then you've really only got like six
paths to look you can go here and then
there and then there or you can go here
and then you can go from oh yeah there's
one you can go here from there to there
and then that's like a really dumb way
to go there so it's like really easy
once you have tangent bug and there's a
way to generalize that so that it's not
just vector geometry in open space but
is you know down to the level where you
like okay these are individual squares I
assumed in to indicate that was really
smart it worked really well I was happy
with it
so there's tangent bug which you can use
there and and you know you could
consider having in tangent bug
especially you can imagine that
headquarters could help out where you
have like these things these that you
need to get around oh my goodness uncle
any way you want to get around them so
that you could have the headquarters
indicate like what is the tangent spot
and he doesn't have to tell you all the
places they're just like waypoints to go
to on your way to the destination and
you know it could it could work pretty
well it could it could keep in mind
there are some undesirable behaviors to
to watch out for when you do something
like this
sometimes allied units that bug in the
opposite direction like that makes a lot
of sense if you have a little obstacle
to get around but if the obstacle is big
sometimes your robots will come at one
another from opposite directions when
passing so you'll have here's the
obstacle and robot a hits the obstacle
and starts going this way robot B hits
the obstacle and starts going this way
robot B is here and a goat tries to go
around him B keeps going this way and a
now is like I don't know where I am I'm
just gonna spin around in midair because
I I thought I was bugging but then the
wall changed like I know I know that
there's like a million movies about how
people are in mazes and then like the
big kicker is supposed to be that the
maze is shifting over time well by now
we're used to it and it's boring in a
movie but when it happens in battle code
it hits close to home
the another another undesirable behavior
to be that you bug around the whole map
and one thing you can try to do is sense
if the terrain is off map again that
would be terrain tiles rain type equals
terrain type dot off map and you could
you could check that but sometimes you
know they'll be like maybe we'll put
neutral mines all array around the edge
of the map and then you won't really
know if you're bugging around the edge
of the map because it'll just look like
neutral mines so they're there there's
another thing to worry about
you could you could turn around a
transient obstacle like an ally as we
mentioned before you know there's
insufficient information for a lot of
things like you know maybe you've got
the perfect a-star algorithm that's
gonna find everything that's the best
technical term for it and you know
you're gonna find everything but you
don't have that much information like
you don't want know where the enemy
mines are you don't know where the enemy
robots are until you get close to them
so and so and so that I think that's
that's fairly well explained you know
we've got everything sort of laid out on
the table here and there I would mention
that here's another use for radio is not
every robot can tell that another robot
is sort of stuck so you might consider
radioing information about robots that
are stuck so that the other robots
allied of course behind them can get out
of the way and you know you can make
this playful in your own way by coming
up with your own comments on on what
anyway that that that made a lot of
sense so they can get out of the way so
let's consider the following case you
have this radio system which consists of
these integers and you need to be able
to post map locations to integers how
are you gonna do that well I got a good
idea for you if you haven't thought of
it already an integer in Java can go
from something like minus 2 billion to 2
billion
so here we're we're radioing integers
and it has to be an integer well I know
a certain thing about 2 billion 2
billion has this many numbers in it 1 2
3 1 2 3 1 2 3 that's a billion yeah I
got it I think that's 2 billion I think
it has two billion cuz it's 2 to the 32
yeah something like that
what
I know what this can contain all I have
to do since a map location starts it has
x and y values starting at zero zero and
going to at most 100 100 and something
tells me that the final maps we give out
won't be that big but maybe they will I
don't know they might be well look at
that 0 and 100 only take up 3 of these
positions in the number I mean you could
do it in binary and encode the
information even more efficiently but
this will do just fine so here's an ears
of thought put the round number in the
first 3 put the x-coordinate in the
second 3 and put the y-coordinate in the
third 3 and now you can tell when you
look at a single integer if it isn't
up-to-date so here what's our rap we'll
have 2 comma round numb comma X Val
comma Y Val and all you would do for
that is you'd say my integer you know
equals round it would be let's be
explicit o'clock get round numb o'clock
the kenra round on x a million a million
there you go plus x value which is i'll
call em x times a thousand plus m dot y
times 1 there you go and that would
doubt encode everything into my integer
and then I could make another function
that sort of unpacks things into a map
location oh my goodness what would that
look like well would be something like
public static and it returns a map
location because that would be really
useful public static map location will
say int to map location yes that will be
really useful and it takes an integer my
integer yes
I'm coding in Microsoft Word I wonder if
everybody has done that and if you're
going to tell me it's OpenOffice that's
true that's true I acknowledge that
let's see here so let's get let's get
the other values on out let's say that
our x value equals my integer at Oh what
am I gonna do here I'm gonna say I'm
gonna take modulo 1
billion is that gonna do it so there's
I'm gonna put spaces in so that I can
see it but I think if you actually put
spaces in it isn't gonna work yes so
that's is that that's my ex Val no
that's my y-value I'm gonna do this in
this order because it'll make it easy in
ex Val equals my integer modulo one I
think I did that you guys got to pay
attention this is the one billion isn't
it yeah I got it I got to make it this
way actually I think they might be they
might be identical anyway if I do it if
I do it yeah so if I oh no this has to
be a billion sorry this has to be a
billion yeah because if I do modulo a
billion then any numbers that are over
here sort of roll off from the two
billion yeah that'll be fine and I'll
just subtract from this from the
millions category is it would that be a
thousand or maybe a million and I'll
subtract off the Y value and now I have
an X Val and finally I mean maybe the
first thing I should do is I should
check to see if my very if my very first
number like if these very first three
numbers I should check to see if those
are decent I hear some whispers but I'm
sure that they're talking about how
amazing this is going to end up being
we'll make a new map location by saying
the output map location well I'll just
call an output lok map location output
look equals now this is a constructor
new map location the same thing we did
yesterday X Val Y Val and I could have a
check in here that verifies that it was
said that the previous round numb so
that it's not out of date that would be
really useful so that's that's a pretty
useful thing to have right there that's
just that's just one of many bytecode
tricks so this is going to be packing a
map location into an integer what's
another one let's consider that you have
a whole stockpile of energy that your
robots are using but early on in the
game you're wasting a lot of that energy
because it's just decaying in your in
your inbox it's just sort of sort of
floating around and then and then it's
going down so why don't you consider
spend byte codes when the number of
Allied BOTS is low or equivalently when
there's a
lot of RC get team power question
it will be the total stockpile that's
right
yeah that's right you'll lose it if so
that's it's it's what's this what's the
comment saying it's I use it or lose it
yeah
so if you're using it you don't lose it
I guess that was not necessary to
explain
I made a program here that may be useful
on this effect
I call it stockpiling and I made it in
Mathematica just because it's nice and
visual so here's an example of
stockpiling resources let's go ahead and
we'll simulate 400 rounds will simulate
the case where the decay multiplier is
0.8 and we'll start with zero BOTS using
zero byte codes so you can see here this
is what you should expect your number of
BOTS to be you're building them
constantly and you finish building them
around turn 300 and you hit a maximum of
40 BOTS if you're using more like let's
do a little bit more realistically
you're using 2,000 byte codes well now
your maximum you're maxing out at 34
BOTS and you can see here that you
quickly decay upward to your maximum
you're 200 and then you only go down bit
by bit as you build more robots you may
for example have a I mean we can we can
look at more examples here and I'll
probably talk about this more on a
strategy lecture but let's say that you
got the fusion upgrade so that the decay
multiplier went from 0.8 to 0.99 so now
we've got 0.99 there
well now you can see that you got up to
44 robots because the decay was much
slower so you got up to a really big
number as you were massing up these
robots and so for about 70 rounds you
were able to you were able to maintain
an increase of 4 robots over the enemy
not a huge benefit if you ask me now if
you stockpile for longer let's see what
effect that would have I guess this is a
bit of a tangent but we just did tangent
bugs so it's relevant but oh let's see
here so where's the where's the oh yeah
num-num rounds round is greater than so
we're only going to start building
robots at round say 200 now we can't
really see what's going on let's
increase the number of rounds in the
simulation to a thousand so now we can
see here
that we are maintaining we're having
five extra robots four slightly longer
it's not that great it's just not that
great let's wait a little bit longer
before we start building so we can try
to stockpile
okay we've stocked by out as much as
possible we still only got five extra
robots Oh actually it's more than five
extra robots let's go down to zero so we
can make sure yeah it's 12 extra robots
on top of 40 so it's a 12 over 40 times
100 is 30% more 30% bonus but you pay
you did it at the price of stockpiling
for 500 turns and by then you'll
certainly be dead
that's a quick look at stockpiling
question yes power is also used for
capturing in my handy dandy unit spec
sheet gosh I did use that term handy
dandy in the spec sheet which I put over
over here on this place which you can
get it on the website
I could I could be going to the website
I'm sure all of you have been there by
now and and if you haven't then you're
missing out this useful battlecode data
sheet which updates from time to time
indicates what takes power so if I just
do control F and the word power we can
see here we this the headquarters
generates 40 power okay we know that
soldiers upkeep to 1 to 2 power in per
turn ok attack power that's that's
irrelevant the generator generates 10
power ok I see that and then it should
also say somewhere that you capture
encampments at a cost of 20 plus this
number units of power so if the intent
if you own one encampment and you are
capturing one encampment then the next
camp and you go to capture will cost
three times the ordinary encampment cost
which is right now 20 so there you have
it that's another use for your power and
it's certainly interesting to consider
that you might need to call suicide on
some of your robots so that you'll get
enough money to buy some of those
encampments because that's a one-time
cost so you might suicide some robots
build an encampment and then build those
robots back again because it is it is
not a continuing upkeep although I do
believe that encampments count as robots
in the extent that they to the extent
that they do require upkeep themselves
let's go back and see how much we have
time for it I'm sure everybody's mouth
is already watering as much as mine is
about the chicken curry among other
things I was over here putting down bike
code tricks and I got sort of
sidetracked let's talk about more bike
code tricks so we let's let's think
about how it might be cheaper oh my
goodness to broadcast an enemy's
location then to sense it let's answer
that question the method cost for
rebroadcast is one and for making a
broadcast that broadcast is also one now
that's pretty small compared to sensing
an enemy location where let's see
sensing an enemy location sensing an
object is twenty five sensing a bunch of
game objects is a hundred I mean one is
less than twenty five often times so
let's check let's check if there are any
other costs associated with it by going
into the specs here under constant
values so here in the in the Java Doc's
we can see that there is also a broad a
broadcast read cost so that also answers
this gentleman's question that there's
also another cost in power this read
cost is a power cost for reading and
broadcasting so this is going to use
0.05 power
I mean it's relatively small compared to
your one one up County positions well
then all of a sudden or read twenty
positions would be point two and that
would be equivalent to using two
thousand byte code so that starts to say
that that's a pretty high cost for
reading in terms of byte code which
suggests that if you want to send things
on messages and be byte code efficient
that it mode it makes the most sense to
send the results of a large computation
rather than the base data on which that
computation is performed let's see here
it's already 549 and I haven't showed
you as many awesome matches as I was
expecting to I'll blast through a few
more byte code tricks and then we'll get
right there make sure to check the byte
code cost of your functions I find it
very helpful to
put in my in my code like a little block
comment that says what the bytecode cost
is and I'll put it right next to the
function so I can say all right that's
the price of that function and how many
times can I use it do I want to use it
is it worthwhile am i improving it one
way to do it is to run the match with
and without that function installed on
your robot and just do the math yourself
but another way is very simple you can
just use clock get byte codes or
something like that there's a function
there and you can just do it before and
after a certain operation and then check
it out you should also try computing
only relevant directions later on I'm
gonna show you a little example of how
you can write code where a robot is is
doing something in two sip in two ways
and it's trying to find out who's
adjacent so it's like alright I I can
move forward and that would put me next
to this many enemies on this many allies
I could move to the left and there would
be this many enemies and this many
allies you kind of want to be next to a
lot of allies and just one enemy so you
can gang up on them that was sort of the
whole idea of of like being intelligent
about your stance and where you are
because you want to be you want to gang
up on the enemy and that's a very local
decision when you when it comes right
down to it sometimes and but if you
can't move in a certain direction don't
compute anything about that direction
because you're not going there anyway
that's a thought I mean of course you
may compute it anyway and then try to
move in that direction and move in the
next closest so but but you could
consider that and I'll show a little bit
so there's a there's a you could
consider right spending things only when
you when it's low cheaper to broadcast
the enemy using that and so on I have
another useful thing when we're looking
at pathing and I'll show it by running a
match I'll run the match of Cold War
which is my player versus hard bot I
have the Cold War player does something
that's similar to the realistic cold war
but I'll do it just I'll do it on
slightly smaller maps you can see what's
going on let's see here let's go on tiny
so I made these maps that are free of
Mines just I don't have to worry about
it so here we've got Cold War and
blue and his goal is to nucleon imme and
what he does is he he pads around over
here around the medbay to defend against
the enemy and the enemy will be just
building these shields and then
attacking and they attacked my med bays
but they get nowhere I don't think I
even lose a single guy so the cold war
is gonna finish massing up a bunch of
troops and when he's done he's gonna
build a nuclear missile and they're
there you could see the progress going
on hello and thank you
yeah and so he's building along the
nuclear missile and and when he's done
it'll be curtains for the other guy
curtains doesn't work we will bury them
but you might ask I can't really tell if
these guys can see those guys or what
there's a you can push the letter A
which gives you sight range and attack
range so that's that's a pretty useful
thing to have there so that's a in the
client viewer there's also another list
of commands like B will turn off the
broadcast range let's look at some more
options I would have liked to go into
the way to store
here's another bytecode trick store the
locations of other units in an integer
array so that instead of having to use
like instead of having to loop through
all enemy bots and check if they're
adjacent for example you can just store
their locations into an array so that
you know where they are then you can
just index into that array and you say
alright this is this is where they are
so your index your indexing into a two
dimensional array and I can talk to you
about how to set those up at another
time but the result is that you can
perform significantly better than you
otherwise would
so here player three kind of works I'm
going to show it we're doing this
calculation where you find the number of
Allied the number of adjacent units can
be pretty helpful so here's here's what
I'm showing on the upper left and the
bottom right are the same robot but what
I've done is I've done if your team is a
then run the code this way if your team
is B then run the code the other way and
this is a demo
this is demonstration so let's back up
just a bit I'll zoom in as much as
possible but that's as good as it's
going to get so let's go
until they're touching so this guy is
computing adjacent robots and he's
printing out the number of adjacent
robots that are enemies that are allied
in fact I think this might yeah this is
the number of allies starting with north
and going around and this guy is
printing out different numbers that are
heuristics so he's for each of the
positions around him he is computing how
many allies there are and how many
enemies there are and he's gonna try to
move in the direction that is that has
the most enemies so he'll either stay
put if his current location has the best
heuristic value or he'll go toward the
best position like if he's gonna try to
you know flank the enemy or get to a
position where he'll gang up on the
enemy and you can see here that the red
player is able to make significant
advances against what was previously
awesome BOTS so you can see I'll show
I'll show again it's very hard to tell
because it's it's a subtle thing that
takes place where it's it's trying to do
an optimization and at a very local
scale so you're taking like good
decisions on a robot by robot basis and
having them translate into good
decisions on a global basis for the
whole team I it was a bit of a close
race though so let's consider making
global decisions here's another here's
another pathing idea where you would be
using the local data from each robot to
decide that you might want to sort of
form a concave around the enemy so let's
do that example and then I'll end with
one final example so this one is a
concave I have them just build up robots
until round 200 so I'll skip until there
and you'll see that the blue team is
gonna sort of back away he's backing
here I'm going forward he's backing away
from the enemy and then when the moment
is right he comes in boom he comes in
and surrounds the enemy and they started
with the same number of units and look
at how many he has left look at the
difference that that makes so you should
really consider having your robots think
about what's close to them nearby and
paths with respect to that I know it's
not exactly you know a star or D star or
whatever but it's something that it's
something that's worth doing at this
point the other guy really can't really
can't return from that
problem I'm just gonna show you one more
example of how things can sort of get
interesting I've changed the constant
values all around a little bit just to
show how things would look if both
players were the player that tries to
avoid the other player now of course
when you write your own you write it in
your own way and it'll behave in that
way so it won't necessarily look like
this and there are things about this
that are just downright stupid but
you're gonna see it happen and I believe
it will be as fun for you as it was for
me so here we're on round 200 I wish I
could slow this down so I'll just click
I'll just click forward you see they're
both avoiding one another and just there
the whole enemy team was backing away
from one guy why like that guy was
moving toward the enemy I think because
he doesn't see them they moved first and
then he moved so he can't even see them
he doesn't think he's that close but
they think they're close because this
guys were about 138 and this guys were
about 139 can you believe it they're
that close oh my goodness so they're
gonna run away from one guy meanwhile
these guys are running away but they're
also sort of edging that way because
they figure that's where the enemies are
cuz it's the enemy headquarters these
guys are running away and they're sort
of self segregating into these like
separate pacts I don't think a single
bloodshed has been spawned that was the
right way of putting it and they'll just
end there likes wrapping around one of
they're gonna trade sides of the map
this is absolutely bonkers
so you can see here that the red is
pretty much gonna abandon his own
headquarters blue is gonna abandon his
because they just you know it got smelly
the tiresome they won't say what
something new in their lives and when we
continue on to the end of the match it's
just a question of which one is going to
be able to deal the damage sooner like
this this guy is saving himself on the
basis of producing units bit by bit he's
like oh if I stop building units for one
second I am dead
I am totally gone keep building units
wait though these guys are eating up all
the resources and these are dying
because of the end of the round like
that is they don't have enough power no
please don't eat all my units please
don't eat my resources you guys should
suicide protect the headquarters you're
doing it wrong
I swear you're doing it wrong no no no
you kind of open that we're killing his
and we're doing a lot of all but we've
taken a lot of damage up oh and then
it's over and so there you have
a little bit of exciting stuff happening
with direction thank you for coming but
let me say let me say that one of these
dishes I believe it's the redder looking
one yeah the one in the middle
chicken vindaloo this time is spicy all
right
so beware that one like don't take too
much of it because these guys know what
they mean when they say spicy thank you
very much